there goes hayes
miss down and away throw to second on
the bag and in time
nobody better than manny pina it had to
be perfect
and it was it normally is with manny
pina
what a throwing on a rocket down to
second and they get it
ogleback had a multi-homer game against
this pirates team
earlier this season swinging a flight
off center field drifting back around
still back it's over his head and off
the wall
urias is going to score all the way from
first base is daniel vogelback cruises
into second it's one-nothing brewers
that's a good start right there how
about that swing by vogelback
does a good job just shortening up with
two strikes
it was a change up and he hit a rope
over the head of brian reynolds in the
center
huh there you go right down the middle
second out two balls and two strikes on
jace peterson
yeah nice one comes back does a nice job
after
the vogelback rbi double it's one
nothing milwaukee
and that'll sneak through
moran in the third base joy cora
checking with him see if he's okay
he's slow to begin with but that was
extra slow
you would hate to see him uh
re-aggravate but it looks like
the way he's about and maybe something
up her body
did something three quarters the way
down the line wrench to something
he's going to stay in there for now
newman steps to the plate with the bases
loaded in one out
and that's exactly what they get
safe at first i'm shocked they didn't go
home there
that's not a routine or guaranteed
double play ball especially with newman
yeah who can run well so it's tied up
and that's pablo reyes
payoff to crow bouncer right back to
adrian
able to flip it underhand to
daniel vogel back and the damage is
limited to the one run
head to the bottom of the second inning
bottom of the order schedule
newman pops it up shallow center
in comes jackie bradley jr and the
inning
is over to a double for ben gamble
that's all
part of the orders scheduled for the
brewers in the fourth
[Applause]
[Music]
there goes the runner swinging a line
drive it's going to be caught by
us growers are going to get a double
play out of it pretty much the only risk
that you take when you're running
on the pitch you know those line drives
turned into easy double plays
and now jacob stalling sends one deep
and clear the deck cannonball coming in
milwaukee to give the pirates the lead
number five for stallings it's 2-1 if he
was frustrated before
not any longer as uh he gets a breaking
ball
and breaks the wall didn't get all of it
and he sends this one towards the middle
lopes has it
flips to adamus very late and they did
get the out
on newman a little bottle there from
lopes
with suitor escapes stalin's gives the
pirates
a two-to-one lead with his home run
after that 10-pitch ab
with lopes this one driven left center
field it's gap
bound lopes on the move he's going to
score
all the way from first luis suryas
digging for
third the throw is right game tied
2-2
the first hit since the first inning for
the brewers and it's luis suryas
delivering
for the run scoring triple i'll tell you
the brewers the the pirates bullpen has
been a bright spot all season long but
the brewers have been able to get to him
in this series
first batter face by the pirate bullpen
maria is able to score
driving the tying run he's at third with
nobody out
garcia to right plenty deep polanco
back
garcia a belated birthday gift his 13th
home run of the season for garcia
and the brewers continue to do damage
against his pirate pen
looked like a cutter up down the middle
of the plate
goes right with it and gives the brewers
a
two red lead gotta face jacob stallings
he gave the pirates the lead momentarily
in the top of the sixth the solo home
run
fly ball center field jackie bradley
junior's got a beat on this one and
boxberger puts up a zero
in the top of the seventh inning
line of fair ball extra bases for manny
pena leading things off here in the
seventh inning
trucks in the second with a double yeah
maddie needed that i mean it's been a
struggle for him
finally he says in the hit column a
leadoff double
see if the brewers can get some
insurance in this inning
3-2 ground ball to the right side jackie
bradley jr gets the job done
pena moves to third with less than two
outs old school right there well done
jbj lefty versus lefty you hear the roar
of the crowd
here comes christian yelich
swing the line drive right field polanco
makes the catch
coming down the line to score is manny
pina
job well done by yelich it's 5-2 that's
just good baseball by the brewers i mean
manny pina with the double jbj gets him
over yellows drives him in
so three and two going back out there
got him fastball cut
three up three down
brewers trying to tack on some more runs
and josh hader
picked up save number 15 in the openers
swing and a miss got the slider
gonzalez thrown out by manny pina for
out number one
yeah that's the pitch you were talking
about earlier i mean not just a fastball
guy anymore he's got the three
oh two slider half swing and a miss
two gone here in the ninth hey commit
the fastball he gives you that
and no chance the 2-2 now to reynolds
he got him haters strikes out the side
and the sweep is complete
over the pittsburgh pirates